ciao reader se vuoi venuti un nuovissimo
[Musica]
finalmente ragazzi un video con jean
marie il problema che abbiamo scelto il
video peggiori si poteva non finire così
ma sicuramente c'è da ridere perché non
sono in grado di cantare anche perché mi
vado a sfidare come non devi saper qatar
davis a conoscerle le parole che ne sarà
allora sarà una bella sfida
allora funziona così ci sono delle carte
ognuno di noi perscara turno una carta e
cita il nome di un cartone dovremmo
cantare una canzone e cene in mente di
quel cartone se la sai se la sappiamo ci
proviamo la cantiamo e da tutto ed
infila tutto dimostra il problema
persiste quando la canzone non la sai tu
te la canti male sbagli parole allora li
interviene edoardo che ora dietro la
videocamera ma poi si traslerà qua
davanti a noi anzi davanti a questa
fantastica ruota e lui e solo lui potrà
farla girare e far varna penitenza a
colui o colei che non ha indovinato la
canzone con la carica dei 58 canzone
certo ma crudelia demon crudelia demon
sole parole però la sapevo e crudele
demoni sapeva le parole di ornica non le
so tutte le brano addio comportati da
burattino come pinocchio una palla
meglio cioè quello ma l'ho fatto di
grattino ferocia lenitivi quindi tutto
per dai bellissima che guardava al
movimento si sa la caduta magicaboola
bibidibobidibooo fa la magia tutto quel
che vuoi tu bibidibobidibooo ad ora mi è
piaciuto perché troppo amichevoli che
hai preso il primo punto della glaciale
ragusa a 77 la sapevo da loro stessi no
ma perché penalizzate marina la tua
performance è stata giudicata non
adeguato il duello con la spada contro
un altro giocatore va in jean e il
nostro momento ho una candela e non ho
paura di usarla è morto
in più
dovete colpo banche celebrità veramente
finge di avere un uncino al posto della
passata stagione l'evergreen comunque io
ho sofferto tanto neanche con 50
a lipari con quanto sei bravo prima in
salina non c'è un mashup ali abad la
vincita adesso metti di qualcos'altro e
l'altra mano ti prego eccolo ragazzi
anche se è difficile ricordarsi che stai
dando cioè no in realtà sembra io penso
che fosse molto più facile in realtà il
vero è vero ma croce perché nella
melodia però le parole alcune non le so
ripescato faccia pescara penne tirava
tutto qui è un bel paesino qui non
cambia mai così che la gente vive a buso
e poi giù per una giostra che fa pensa
vita cira insieme hanno di nuovo
[Musica]
canini bianca ne risentiranno
e poi basta questa cosa non l'accetta
[Musica]
dai promossi amigas sito online
richard long cena il titolo la canzone
ok e aprì matelica inserito penitenza
mi dispiace l'hanno mai chi di qualcosa
sul fatto come si va da piccolo è questa
la vita che esiste un premio per
l'ingenuo e o lo già vinto da tempo ma
nessun uomo vale tanto di delusioni in
avute troppe cosa crede amica aspetta
c'è il momento della performance
ma guardate un po lezioso questa
ferrario sia una che sa mai
sognato che non so dove c'è una nuova
terra sta aspettando me la gente mi ha
spento passero saluterà dicendo questa è
casa tua casa è ormai è fatta mamma papà
poi l'ho sbagliato erano in porta ma la
porta non è un passo di camerino perché
lui facili poi canta una canzone che
pura di aria e facendo battarino o di
un'altra canzone non so paolo perino
fatto per niente quando io l'allergia
toy story
hai un amico me tutto un nuovo amico
[Musica]
strumentale da cioè strumenti
instrumental e somma da romy puoi fare
l'ennesima penitenza marino la voglio
fare va fatta la voglio fare leggi si
parla come il topolino fino a quando
canterai un uomo marco che fa questa
questa cosa la neve che cade sopra di me
copre tutto con sublima in questo in
questo remoto regno la reggina sono io
ma la marina ha questo problema se sto
pescando legge la mano qua visto meno
riflesso attuativo rifarlo vara cioè lei
guarda al trovate anche se per la state
bank crede una perla e poi mentre ci
penso crea un rock this is me dei sismi
ammazzati libero norma ha far
volteggiare la tua coda come la
sirenetta loro è tutto tuo ma lombardo
sai che sogno si avvera chiusi i doriani
in orari a marina di fare penitenza ma
maritele fa le infinite semplicemente
perché si prenota senza sapere anche di
carta ha pescato imita qualche
personaggio dalla carte in gioco grandi
poteri cosmici e del suo uomo buono e
cartone i sogni son desideri
di sia nei sogni con sincerità cantato
che vuoi
c'è ormai il bastimento persson fix
suite ed home screen parchi walls minimo
scorsi non prima comunque contiamo mento
momento momento momento importante
evento della territorio 10 posto dietro
allora devo fare i complimenti a jean
perché sinceramente mi ha stupito se era
molto preparato ho fatto la scelta
giusta a scegliere lui per queste celle
è una stata una sfida molto interessante
la pastina interessante non c'era uno
più bravo dell'altro ci siamo compensati
abbia a livello di conoscenza ok marine
sa allora spero tantissimo speriamo che
vi sia piaciuto questo video noi ci
siamo divertiti molto esperti stati gli
ospiti anche voglia vederlo
e mi raccomando tenete d'occhio call e
gianmarco perché presto uscirà un video
sul suo canale insieme a me allora
mariners e colpo di scena abbiamo fatto
10 punti ciascuno 9 oro scuro e quindi a
questo punto chiediamo ha votati sapere
sotto nei commenti chi secondo voi ha
vinto veramente questa channels chi ci
ha messo quel qualcosa in più mi
raccomando tenete d'occhio anche cai
gianmarco perché presto uscirà un video
che hanno girato insieme sul suo canale
e niente speriamo che vi siate divertiti
tantissimo e quindi al prossimo video
insieme
ciao ciao a tua a tono
[Musica]
ciao